hi there steve here again on my korean
challenge and
you know i just had a conversation with
uh with hannah
uh
in korean
and uh
i have to i did it on my iphone i sent
it over to her in korea and then she
matches them up because she videoed
herself on her iphone so that then we
put them together and it's better than
the quality that we get through skype
but what i wanted to talk about today
was patience in language learning
and i was thinking about this all day
even before i had my conversation with
with hannah
because you know i'm listening to these
podcasts in korean
and increasingly i sense that i
understand that i can read it more
quickly i can understand it when i read
and yet increasingly i'm getting
frustrated at the fact that i still
can't understand it
when they speak now granted it depends
who's speaking the the main host is kim
jong-bay
he speaks so quickly
i just can't get what he's saying
some of the people he invites on there
korean politicians discussing the
political crisis in korea and so forth i
can sometimes understand them better
because they speak a little bit more
slowly and i keep hoping that with the
amount of reading that i'm doing in
korean and listening
that i'll get better as understanding
kim jong bae because he's 50 of of what
i'm listening to and i just can't
understand them and i don't really have
the sense that i'm getting any better i
keep hoping that i'm going to get better
at understanding it because
you know i really don't have many anyone
ready to speak to in korean but i i want
to understand these um
political podcasts uh i
rode my bicycle off to the stores 20 15
minutes away
and so i put on some ukrainian i mean
given the amount of time i spent on
ukrainian i have spent less time on
ukrainian than on on korean and i
understand them they're talking about
all kinds of stuff
ukrainians planning to test some rockets
and the russians have threatened to
you know
send rockets back at them if they test
the rockets a whole bunch of stuff
that's happening and
i can understand the ukrainians i i
hardly spend any time on ukrainian but
of course i had russian i had checked
so
korean even though i have japanese and i
have chinese it's proving difficult and
i sort of felt you know
one has to be patient because i still
believe i will eventually get to my goal
of being able to understand these
podcasts but it's not going to happen as
quickly as i would like
and there's many things in language
learning that don't happen as quickly as
we would like
and
i think
the old adage about how we
overestimate
the speed of short-term change and we
underestimate long-term change
so people expect for example that um
i don't know the internet arrives and
people oh well within three years
everybody will be on the internet and it
doesn't happen in three years but then
lo and behold in 10 years
the change is even more dramatic than we
expected and there's lots of examples
like this in fact it might be an example
even in so far as global warming is
concerned i hope not
but there are many examples many
examples like that where
we overestimate the short term
change expecting something to happen and
then before you know it
that longer term change has occurred and
i think it's the same with language
learning we expect that we're going to
learn quickly and we don't so we have a
tendency to get discouraged and then if
we stay with it all of a sudden what do
you know i actually improved more than i
expected
and
you know and i having learned languages
and of course some go faster than others
languages like romanian went quickly and
ukrainian and stuff
but the korean is certainly taking a
long time and and it's it's it's
it's a long it's a long road
but i know i'll get there and now on the
positive side when i spoke to hannah and
i haven't spoken korean since the last
time i spoke to hannah
and she noticed it and i must say even i
noticed it while speaking and you can
judge for yourself when you eventually
see that video
i have improved i have improved i'm
using
more words i'm speaking more naturally
so while i'm
trying to understand
someone else will take that trying to
understand kim jong bae and i'm not
understanding him as well as i would
like in fact i am improving
so
some survey i'm sure
uh so the lesson is
be patient stay with the program and you
will get there
and now i will stop this and hopefully
that call will go away